with a ridiculous attempt to blame
Republicans for America's deadly drug
crisis Biden tweeting quote Maga house
Republican proposals would slash funding
for border security A Move That Could
allow nearly 900 pounds of fentanyl into
our country we need more resources to
secure the Border not less and now
Republicans are firing back
he's just full of you know what honestly
does he believe that Americans are going
to buy the fact that Republicans who
have been screaming and stomping and
going to the border for the last several
years are actually looking to cut border
patrol agents if you look at the
president's own budget he's only adding
100 border patrol agents we need more
than two thousand under this
Administration the Democrats don't think
there's a problem and they're not going
to do anything to try to solve it they
just really don't want to solve the
issue
so Jesse I think this was the definition
of gaslighting they smear border patrol
agents and they're really wanting more
agents so that they can just process
more people not to actually Patrol the
Border it's like Republicans want to
defund the police
this guy has been in Washington for what
40 years never been to the Border it
explodes under his watch and he blames
the Republican party and he lies right
out into everyone's face and the rest of
the media doesn't even say anything
about it the rest of me doesn't want to
care they don't think they don't even go
to the Border unless Trump has someone
in a cage that uh Biden built himself
I'm sick of this guy lying about
Republicans and not doing anything to
fix this country's problem that's why
everybody hates politicians because
they're all talking no action well when
the president was in Canada he also kept
lying about the number of border
crossings take a listen
since we created dedicated Pathways in
the United States the number of migrants
arriving on our Southern border has
dropped precipitously and I command
Canada for stepping up with a similar
program opening new legal Pathways for
up to 50 000 migrants to come to Canada
from countries in the Western Hemisphere
touch your jaws almost on the floor it
is almost on the floor I mean first of
all he he says that now Republicans want
to slash funding for the border and the
amazing part of it is that if you look
at what's going on at the border
4.4 million people have come to the
Border since he's been president okay
which is a hundred and ten percent
increase over the prior Administration
but the greatest part of it is that the
drugs that are being seized are
minuscule compared to the number of
people coming in so you had 1.1 million
drug seizures in the first year and now
we're down to 600 000 drug seizures with
4.4 million people coming in I mean it's
an inverse ratio and then the guy who
never went to the border for 47 years
now wants to talk about the Republicans
wanting to reduce the number of border
patrol that's ridic ridiculous because
he asked for this number because he
wants more people to come in the
Republicans asked for this number and
they're being reasonable about it so he
says oh they want to Slash Mine no we
don't want a slash yours we want a
reasonable number and then on the issue
of fentanyl cracks me up the President
says
um you know the Republicans are going to
allow 900 more pounds of fentanyl to
come in The Amazing part is the first
time that Biden ever said the fentanyl
kills was in July of 2022. he couldn't
even get the words out of his mouth and
now he wants to blame the Republicans
he's gaslighting which is so polite
Jessica
so the Republicans have a freedom caucus
problem
until they put out their own budget
which McCarthy can't do because he's
promised everything to a bevy of
lunatics within his party he stuck with
the fact that the only proposals for the
budget are coming from
a different kind of Republican who do
want to Slash 2 000 border jobs they
want to cut back they want smaller
government that's what the freedom
caucus is about so those are the numbers
you're saying right now according to
this he wants to reduce the number of
border patrol agents you're saying that
I am saying that border patrols you're
saying the Republican Party border staff
and it's a freedom caucus I'm just
saying if you if you don't want ads that
say that Republicans want to cut Social
Security and Medicare put out your
budget that makes it clear to the
American public that you are not going
to touch their entitlements put your
values on the line Kevin McCarthy don't
let the freedom caucus speak for you
because you're going to get add after ad
after ad about what they're proposing so
they claim it's border patrol agents but
it's really border staff are you saying
though that the Democrats would prefer
more border patrol agents because I hear
that's racist I mean I'm sure if the
Republicans were pushing that it would
be just another sign of a xenophobic uh
Republican Party but I love it when they
talk about how much fentanyl they
captured right it's like completely
meaningless without the denominator it's
like that's the bottom part of the
fraction if you don't remember Jesse
I'll help you later it's like I
confiscated 16 beers for my son's party
yes there were 17
000 beers but it's like you know it's
like we confiscated 200 pounds of fence
and all uh yeah 250 that's pretty good
but 200 about a 10 000 that's wrong I do
think that we're moving towards some
kind of solution with the drug thing
we're gonna have to uh we're gonna have
to have some direct contact with the
cartels uh militarily or even possibly
politically who knows you know they're
running the country uh the stuff is way
too easy to transport what you
confiscate will not matter because it's
miniscule and that's the price of doing
business right so they just make more
they're easier to make than Doritos so I
think that that is going to be the thing
and then I think we will have to and I
see it happening restrict the
restrictions on legal opiates are going
to fall because you need to reduce the
demand on street drugs okay hi everyone
I'm Brian Kilmeade I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now